well good evening for London welcome to
Piers Morgan on Sunday uh we start the
show with some very sad breaking news
the Irish music legend Sinead O'Connor
has died at the age of just 56. she was
a troubled and Beautiful Soul Fearless
uncompromising shocking courageous she
was a rebel at heart she took on the
Catholic Church she used a prime time
performance on ustv the stage of protest
even as everyone warned her it could
ruin her career
above also she Enchanted Millions with a
song that's known across the world and
across Generations few people can truly
say their voice to find an era but
sinead's dead put simply nothing
compared to Sinead O'Connor
[Music]
nothing compared to you
won a statement tonight the singer's
family said it is with great sadness
that we announced the passing of our
beloved Sinead a family and her friends
are devastated and I'm sure that
millions of people across the world will
share that sentiment generally calls led
a very turbulent life she was said her
rebellious streak was driven by the
abuse she suffered as a child and that
music rescued her is certainly Unleashed
to creative talent that made her world
famous she struggled with her mental
health for many years and talked very
openly and powerfully about that and
tragically she lost her 17 year old son
Shane to Suicide just 18 months ago I
had a number of number of exchanges with
Sinead and interviews over the years
they were most definitely uncensored
this was the last time I interviewed her
Sinead exactly we go back a long way we
do I used to write about you as a young
pop writer we used to lockhorns clash
blah blah blah I never doubted your
talent I mean the one thing that Rose
above all the controversies all the
stuff was that you just had this
wondrous voice and to hear you now if
anything even richer your voice I think
than it was back then it's a magical
thing to hear I mean at your heart
you're just a great singer aren't you
yeah I think I was very young I wasn't
ready for the type of success inverted
commas that happened you know I mean I
wasn't really setting out to be a pop
star so I didn't really fit the mold I
was more of a punk
she was and she was a unique talent a
unique character well I'm joined then by
RTE radio presenter from Ireland Dave
Fanning his interview she made multiple
times Dave uh very sad this news it
really gave me a jolt when I read this
just before I came on air you knew
Sinead very well you interviewed her
she's an Irish music legend of course
what is your reaction to this news
tonight
dreadfully sad I mean an Irish Cultural
Legend as much as an Irish music legend
obviously it's the music that people
would know are best by I mean she's got
about 10 Studio albums she must have 30
collaborations with some of the biggest
artists around obviously she took
Prince's song and made it into the
greatest love song of all time there it
is there yeah I mean absolutely no
question about it it's her song her
first two albums just broke every moment
you could imagine the next ones were all
quite kind of experimental sometimes the
Shand knows the old Irish singing one
there was a reggae one they didn't
always work but the last two albums that
she made were just a great collections
of new pop songs and they were really
good and with David Holmes then the
Belfast musician she had another one an
11th one coming out I don't know if it
still will I'm not sure but it was the
cultural impact that she had I mean she
was self-deprecating she was pragmatic a
very sharp Observer she was
uncompromising and she had no regrets
about anything at all and she was an
absolute icon to a certain generation of
Irish people and that Generation Now is
anything between the age of 20 and maybe
45 or 50. the older generation they
didn't necessarily like all the things
she did tearing up the picture of the
Pope on TV 25 I mean 30 years ago was
obviously something that didn't
necessarily go down well with some
people but how prescient was she
everything she was saying every reason
she did it came true 10 years later with
the Dreadful Dreadful
um Revelations of just exactly how crazy
the church was yeah I mean she was
controversial she was outspoken but she
spoke her mind I always felt that it was
sincere you know I had some great
run-ins with her where she'd tear into
me and the next thing would be drinking
Guinness and she'd be smothering me in
kisses and love and she was like that
she was a contrarian figure I think she
liked rattling cages and she liked
telling you what she really thought of
you whether it was good or bad and so
you know I feel very uh like I say I
feel very sad about this news I also
feel it probably I don't want to guess
here but it probably can't be
unconnected to the tragedy about her son
who died only 80 few months ago of
course taking his own life well I don't
want to be too sad all the time about
something and this is still like just
kind of trying to to put this grief into
some kind of um perspective but in some
ways she was a bit Piers Morgan she was
an Asian provocateur in many ways she
really knew how to Rattle people's cages
and was able to stand up to whatever had
to be said to her in terms of wrong
she'd say no here's why I'm not wrong
and she was fun and she was great she
was very fearless and fragile often at
the same time no regrets she did put
herself into some very very tough
situations and you kind of used to
wonder and say why is she doing this the
very first interview she did she did
with me on the radio back in 87
direction or whatever it was and then
the last thing she did was on stage in
Dublin the thing in Britain called the
Mercury music prize in art we call it
the choice prize and at Vicar Street in
Dublin she came out first time since
Shane had died and I had to give her the
award for her second album like it was a
classic album award thing and I didn't
even think she'd come to collect it and
she did and she came out stage and
smiled and honestly not so much the
standing ovation but the love in the
room I know it's got a cliche so I'll
just leave it at this everybody wants to
put their arms around her she knew that
and smiled all her way home fantastic
Dave thank you so much for joining me
I'm so sorry for your loss for the
country's loss you know she really was
an iconic figure and I thought you
summed her up absolutely perfectly or
they can already hear her ranting about
you saying she was Piers Morgan that
would be just about the last thing she'd
want to hear but she'd also have a wry
smile because she uh she and I had a a
Bittersweet but always fun uh
relationship Dave thank you I appreciate
that look take it easy